listen carefully guys it's very very
bizarre and strange
if you listen to the tracks and the
music these instruments of iblees
of course you're gonna want to do things
that he he's gonna be pleased with
because i don't want to expose who i am
so i listen to the music video to hear
the lyrics
aki for one and a half day this track
was stuck in my head
and i started to get evil thoughts
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are wearing shadows so
this is a unique video because
in this video i'm covering the same
topic i already covered but there's a
reason
behind it i got a message from my
brother that i know who's in the dawah
who obviously don't want to be
named not that he's done anything wrong
but he's sharing his experience with us
and he sent this message to me on
whatsapp and i want to read it to you
guys because something really strange
happened with this whole
music thing you know this whole satanic
little nice x music thing that he
released recently
and subhanallah it shows you in this
very text message how
dangerous music is how dangerous it is
this is the message from him so he says
i wanted to share this with you because
i don't want to expose who i am
i was planning on doing a video on this
whole satanic music video of that little
x guy so i i so i listen to the music
video to hear the lyrics
yeah um so obviously he when it's
maybe he couldn't get access off the
lyrics anywhere else so we have to
listen to it to maybe do a video from it
yeah okay
i obviously avoided looking at this
disgusting parts however obviously when
listening to this trap i had a
i had to of course replace certain bits
to catch what he was saying
now i haven't listened to music since i
started practicing eight years ago
and to me this music was not even
attractive at all
when i was going over it so when he was
listening he said he didn't find
attractive at all
anyways as i said i decided not to do
the video as you covered it
and so did brother smart agenda listen
carefully guys
it's very very bizarre and strange
however something strange happened
i was on tick tock and randomly a video
popped up
of some guy talking about how to make
money
uh how to make money by selling stuff
from tk maxx to amazon
consumers thinking about amazon yeah but
in the background a music was playing
and it sounded familiar
and for some reason i thought let me
watch the video
on tick tock again and hear it so you
don't take it off when you watch it
replace itself
i let the video repl uh replay itself
and i realized
it's that satanic music well i swear
upon allah
subhanahu ta'ala aki for some reason i
couldn't help but want to listen
again and again and again
until i was like i would be lying in the
shaytan regime i came off and i was like
what the hell
just happened aki i do quran every
single day i recite quran in my free
time
in the car i never listen to music aki
for one and a half day this track was
stuck
in my head and i started to get evil
thoughts
aki i had to listen to surah baqarah and
quran for one whole day
and eventually it got out of my head i
know you already did a video on this
filthy
little iblees but please convey these to
the people convey this
to the people may allah bless you chose
you subhanallah people who come and say
you know music is permissible
yeah and let alone you know and then
they use these kind of music as well or
whatever it may be yeah okay
music is very dangerous there is a lot
of studies show how it has an influence
on the way you
think the way you act the way you behave
the way you talk and
it has a whole impact on your thought
process
okay so seeing this coming from a
brother who's practicing
for him to come and say that he
he got affected somebody who does this
somebody who abstains from major sins
somebody
who prays somebody who does quran yeah
okay when i say he was like some super
righteous person but somebody who does
that
for music to penetrate his mind
over a matter of a few tracks and for
some reason he
doesn't he can't help but listen to it
shows you how
dangerous music this filthy music is and
music like this that satanic clear cut
they might have some satanic words you
don't know man that must be they might
be staring there you don't know
it could be all kinds of stuff in there
to misguide people
allah says in the quran shaytan iblees
is your enemy take him as an
enemy yeah a lot of you guys have
enemies and people you don't like
and you will do anything to protect
yourself against them and keep an eye
out against them why do you not do the
same with iblis
why do you not do the same with shaytan
now this brother he listened to it for
um
because he wanted to learn the lyrics
whatever it may be he had to do a video
about a reminder
the point is this there are people out
there outright listening to this
it's their daily life going to the gym
etc in your system then you're surprised
i don't want to praise allah
well of course you're not going to want
to praise allah you don't find a
connection with allah
well of course you know
the quran and music cannot stay in the
same heart
one needs to be kicked out if the music
is penetrating the heart
the quran will leave
now brothers and sisters i'm not saying
it's a major sentence listen to music
i'm not saying that i thought the
opinion is haram
yeah however the point that we're trying
to make here brother sisters
is that music has an impact on you
okay in your if you're in a haram
relationship love music they will
destroy you
so that's why i wanted to do this video
to tell you guys
and share this with you to be careful
and stay away from it listen to the
quran
if you listen to the quran if you listen
to the quran of allah
of course you would want to build a
connection with allah you're reading his
kalam
how could you not and if you listen to
the tracks and the music
these instruments of iblees of course
you're going to want to do things that
he
he's going to be pleased with brothers
and sisters in a nutshell this is what
the video is about i don't want to keep
it long
share this with your friends and family
this is very very important and while
he this is a reality this is no joke so
till next time guys
i hope you guys have benefited and share
this with your friends and family
and protect yourself from music take a
step at a time to leave it
yeah okay let's take a step at a time to
leave music slowly slowly slowly i was
addicted to music i
loved music i never did drugs or alcohol
any of them again
music was like a dumping me rush for me
i love it it would get me high
but eventually with nasheeds and the
quran i replaced it
and music is one of the biggest fitness
to me today yeah
it's very very bad so i try my best to
abstain from it
totally prevention is better than cure
may allah bless you guys
till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh